foreign
[Music]
where you headed to
a shooting in Marinette
put that 10 foot
Hey sir so the vehicle is your vehicle
is that correct
okay yeah cause
yeah I'm just looking I'm looking for
something to verify that you're a US
Marshal all right
the voicemails I love some messes okay
all right yeah I'd like to shift in
about two hours we're shift at oh
unfortunately I get my car yeah fair
enough yeah hopefully we can get this
resolved really quickly all right thanks
hey we got something on the phone wants
to ask you a few questions okay
all right go ahead
Gary Lambert
I work out at Texas but they got me down
they got me down at Florida right now
looking into uh Marion Oaks there's two
gang members two gangs out there that
are riding on a four-wheeler with a hole
on it busting into people's houses
and I got a call so I chase
what's that
Dallas
okay my second house
exactly I know exactly yeah exactly
all right
last week I'm sorry
what's that one weeds I got red bugs eat
me up chasing the guy through it
all right do me a favor just go ahead
and turn around for me
temperature has behind you back
or what I'll explain it to you
and the rest of my life well
all right so you're going to be arrested
for impersonating a police officer okay
I'm gonna go ahead and read this to you
okay
and who do you work for who are you
employed by
the United States Marvel so U.S Marshals
okay he told me that you don't have your
credentials with you but they're in your
well on my charger and your charger
award vehicle okay who's a charger
register too
that's my personality so why would the
Marshalls outfit your personal vehicle
with lights and sirens
in Texas it's not like here okay
you won't have cars like this we have a
Florida tag I know
turn turn the knob on
[Music]
hey how long have you worked for the uh
US Marshals
three years three years okay I'm sorry
I'm finishing up at vote Tech and with
the coochie right now to go to work for
Marion County so to do what to do
coming down the road forget to call my
cell phone hey go see the
four-wheeler out there on the Drone can
you come help us
my squad in Texas if you look through my
phone you'll see the 941 area code but
Squad what do you mean by Squad they
sent three or four of us down here who
is they
the Rangers the Rangers
which Rangers played the baseball team
no hell no okay so what ranges
the Marshalls the Marshalls yeah so what
um where do you work out at Texas
Dallas Dallas
what's your District
account
if you're a U.S Marshal you don't know
okay that's our Squad
okay but there's only a few of us here
a few of you would I be one of those no
I'm not a U.S Marshal I don't know I see
it back
well here's my credentials I am actually
a special Deputy U.S Marshal
yeah here are my credentials
mine are in my car
these your credentials like this are in
there I have one just identify that okay
I would say probably not
because I'm asking you very easy
questions to be able to identify
yourself and you're not
who's your supervisor out of Texas
yes sir you're the right supervisor uh
Jim Willis Jim Willis yeah what do you
do
for the United States Marshals
I normally just do right
raids yeah okay who do you work for
I just told you twice like okay so where
do you work for the fugitive task force
you work for the district Marshals no
who do you work for task force you work
for the task force people are running we
do raids all I do is right okay listen
to me for just a second I'm going to
give you a little bit of an out or
whatever
um I know you're not a U.S Marshal I'm a
U.S Marshal right I know for a fact 100
you are not with the US morphers okay so
I would just want to know why
you would try to identify as a U.S
Marshal was it to like get around
traffic no
okay so what were you trying to do
[Music]
I told you twice I was responding to a
couple
with the U.S Marshals yes
you don't know about the drones out
there flying over sir there is nothing
like that I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
little tip Pro tip okay there's only
three of us in this County you are not
one of the other two
okay
that's a pro tip